hey Mike how's it going hey Amer I'm
just waiting on these deep machine
learning models to Train using
tensorflow but it's taking forever do
you know any way we could possibly speed
them up sure
well what approaches to use tensor
processing units or TP use then Abel you
to train and run predictions on
tensorflow machine learning models
faster than ever
okay sounds pretty good but what exactly
is a TPU I've heard of GPUs but what
does a TPU do differently well here let
me show you
[Music]
here we have a comparison of a GPU and
TPU the modern GPU usually has two and a
half to five thousand arithmetic logic
units in a single processor that means
you could execute thousands of
multiplications and additions
simultaneously but the GPU is still a
general-purpose processor that has to
support millions of different
applications in software this means that
for every single calculation the GPU
needs to access registers or shared
memory to read and store the
intermediate calculation results causing
a bottleneck TP use Cartland word
processors control rocket engines are
execute bank transactions but they can
handle massive multiplications and
additions for neural networks at
blazingly fast speeds while consuming
much less power and inside a smaller
physical footprint so let's look at
actually setting one up first we need to
launch a cloud shell from the cloud
console we're going to use a TPU tool
run the following command to setup a
compute engine virtual machine and a
cloud TPU with associated services this
combination of resources and services is
called a cloud TPU flock you can use a C
TPU up command in the output message the
name is a name of your TPU resource
which defaults to your username and the
zone is a default Geographic zone for
your compute engine
once created the ctp you command
connects us to the compute instance with
cloud TPU attached ok great so we have a
TPU but how do we check that
everything's up and running good
question we're going to test our
environment by executing a simple
tensorflow script this script is written
in Python and performs a simple
computation let's run the script now of
course you don't want to leave these
resources running so we'd better make
sure to spin them down when we're done
first we'll disconnect from the compute
engine VM with the exit command then
we'll run this command to delete the VM
and its associated cloud TP you see TPU
delete and then add the name of your VM
tepees are specifically made to make
matrix calculations faster so you
definitely want to attach them to any VM
is used for machine learning don't
forget to subscribe for more great
Google cloud platform content
[Music]